Twitter's in chaos man so basically what
happens is people have been uh creating
accounts signing up for Twitter blue on
the iPhone getting instantly verified
and somebody made a fake Twitter account
for Eli Lilly a big Pharma company and
tweeted that insulin would be free and
then first thing their market cap just
collapses stock price plummeting
billions and uh the speculation is that
the fake verified tweet that went viral
convinced people that some big move was
happening and it caused chaos in the
market
Twitter has suspended Twitter blue you
can no longer get verified Elon shut it
down wow it's getting crazy they brought
back the double verification for
advertisers so now they're verified and
then they also have an extra
verification yo if the end result of all
of this is that Twitter just blows up I
ain't gonna cry all that much about it I
mean isn't that positive to having the
social network for sure but so be it
it's the activist organizing ground and
people who believe in Liberty and
individualism are banned from it so yeah
okay fine whatever but that's an
interesting story in and of itself we
got a lot more to talk about Kerry Lake
she says she's not going to be giving up
the the current trends suggest she will
win even though she's down however
that's just a trend when people when uh
when the experts they come out and
they're like looking at 2020's data it
looks like the last ballots coming
through are absentee drop-offs the most
most of them and those ski Republican
but the trend may not be predictive we
don't know so it's entirely possible she
doesn't however again based on the
trends that we've seen last year and the
and they're playing out exactly the same
way this year they do believe she will
win but it is not over so we'll talk
about that the other big news Lauren
bobert's now winning and expected to win
despite all the mockery people are
throwing at her but that's it and uh
I don't know I don't know to what degree
the story is true but Ann Coulter is
basically saying that Donald Trump is
not going to support Walker and Georgia
for the runoff which is just crazy
because okay fine whatever but you know
look as long as Republicans win the
house I think we'll get to see some
something happen in the next couple of
years
so it's gonna be a lot of fun before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member you know the drill join
us click that button to help support our
work we got a bunch of really awesome
videos we had Mike I don't know I don't
know we're doubling up the audio that
was from the website we got uh special
members only with Milo yiannopoulos that
uh you definitely want to check out and
then we had a Members Only Yesterday
with CJ and Chad Prather where we talked
about a CBS show this is insane that has
a has a Milo yianopolis based character
accusing DeSantis of
let's just say not acquiring consent for
adult activities it's just it's
absolutely insane we talk about that we
break that down if you want to watch
check it out and we're going to start
sending knickknacks randomly to
commenters you know every week or so
we're gonna pull some random comments
from the members only section hit you
guys up and be like yo hey we're going
to send you one of the knickknacks from
the show we've got Post-its from Milo he
wrote about censorship we're going to be
sending those out soon and then we've
got a bunch of other stuff we'll
probably just give all of Ian's stuff
away because you got too much black 100
rocks they're mine too they're they're
his okay fine I'll give some rocks away
let's do it Ian's rock you we want a
ruby one of his rocks yeah all right
everybody so smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
right now share it everywhere if you
really want to help joining us today to
talk about this and so much more is the
ever lovely Amanda millius welcome back
thanks who are you uh the person who
um is allergic to drinking that uh is
having coffee and uh that is nice yeah I
tell your entire listeners to just relax
everything's gonna be fine are people
commenting about it probably uh it was a
Hot Topic it's been a hot topic for the
rest of my life thank you very much but
Chad Chad Prather did leave tequila on
the table no dude no no as I said I
don't Milo's Wine's right here by the
way no I'm good
um and we all saw what happened people
literally asked me if I quaaluded myself
wow yeah don't make those anymore I mean
I can understand why it's like you have
this long career you're doing all this
work no I don't I've done all these
things and people are like you're the
drunk no no that happened so it's sorry
at CPAC or anywhere if I go to like any
conference that's not like natcon where
like I know everybody
um not seven out of 10 people will come
up to me and they'll be like hey are you
a man to Melius and I'm like yeah I'm
like okay they want a picture like or
they're like oh your movie meant so much
to me or like as it used to be now it's
just like God that was really funny you
were just hammered on Tim cast can I get
a picture and I'm like okay
well you're sober now yeah I uh and and
I can explain like I'm literally
allergic to alcohol so like we're having
some coffee we've got some lip gloss I
don't know if you need some if anybody
needs some lip gloss and we've got some
water I've got I've got turmeric coffee
I'm really excited for this dude that's
awesome if that's gonna be good for your
uh your whole system I like that so
Amanda thanks for hanging out we all
having me back of course of course we
also have the the very Intrepid and
famous coronemic Hi how are you so who
are you good sir uh well cornemic I am
an actor writer producer and uh
all-around good guy all around yeah yeah
not available though sorry ladies what
what uh What uh for work or personal
is there something someone else may
remember you from is there a show or
anything you want to uh oh loads of
stuff I mean I I started acting as a as
a child actor and uh I think the first
movie I did was with Francis Ford
Coppola uh called Tucker the man in his
dream playing Noble Tucker Jeff Bridge's
son and that but then I did uh the last
season of Webster I was Nikki
Papadopoulos I was uh I lit I shared a
room with Webster for for a year while
my uh parents were off teaching Africans
how to grow potatoes that was true to
the storyline by the way wow and uh and
then went on to do uh Parker Lewis Can't
Lose not too long after that
um loads of movies in between that and
Stargate and then was on Supernatural
for a while and uh a bunch of just tons
of stuff going on right now Stephen
King's It And also was in the stand I
was in the scene series The Stand
playing Harold louder crazy movie yes
yes that was great the original
originally the good one the good one
yeah the one that's always the good one
yeah
just for Red Dawn as well obviously like
and Apocalypse Now a lot of people who
watch are big fans of Stargate so
obviously the the chat was all over
there yeah the Stargate is Real by the
way I just want everybody to know that
uh yeah someone believes you right I'm
like oh I knew it all right he's proved
it I think so you were a child actor and
like I don't know if this is too
personal or not but like they tried to
make me do that too because my parents
are from Hollywood and I grew up there
um so you made it through you never got
raped or anything you're good uh Lord
Lord knows I did not but I did go to
Alfie soda pop club which was rape
Central for kids Whoa man you made it
out you're like the only one yeah
there's nothing funny about it but have
you ever been hypnotized no I have not
yes maybe you should try it and just see
if make sure no no no no certainly not
all right uh thanks for joining us
thanks we got Luke of course well that's
a very 100 sober well that's a very
interesting uh necklace there a corn so
this should be oh a very Illuminating
conversation I don't know if you're
trying to get recruited it but I don't
know if this is the show to do it anyway
my name is Luke guardowski here of VR
change.org I come here with one simple
message become ungovernable yeah I love
that the less government the better in
my opinion and if you agree you could
get the shirt on the best
politicalshirts.com I want to talk about
the necklace I want to talk about
everything people are talking about in
the chat room so it should be a great
conversation what necklace is it what is
it oh it's a free Masonic one yeah yeah
that'll be interesting let's talk about
it absolutely dude okay so is the main
Masonic temple in Washington the one in
Alexandria is it in my brain like is it
it's the George Washington name I
thought it's the biggest one the
Scottish at the top what is it doing to
my brain what I'm not sure
satellites that represent energetic
shifts apparently all right all right
well we'll we'll talk about it we got
Ian though I defer my time to the people
talking about Masonic imagery no I'm
just kidding
um I don't have anything to start off
with except I found out whites can be
transformed of material capable of
filtering microplastics from seawater
well there's nothing that eggs can't do
dude yeah make yourself some challenge
some eggs guys what's up y'all got some
raw eggs we can slonk real quick
five before the show yeah we have
hundreds of cooked eggs they were cooked
uh surge what's happening Brother hey
just hanging out hopefully I don't screw
up my intro today
all right let's jump into this first
story we have this tweet from unusual
whales says this is wild yesterday a
fake account tweeted that Eli Lilly and
Co was giving insulin for free it was
verified on Twitter Lily is now down
five percent or roughly 20 billion
dollars here's the tweet it gets crazier
because it's not just Eli Lilly they
tweeted out with his fake it's Eli
Lillian Co verified we are excited to
announce insulin is free now take a look
at this from Investors Business Daily
Eli Lilly Dives after fake Twitter
account promises free insulin takes Novo
Nordisk sanify with it
Twitter's Twitter's uh awesome Twitter
is going crazy there was a bunch of uh
fake posts that were pretty uh hilarious
George Bush was I was just going to say
the George W bush one me too yeah George
W bush allegedly posted I miss killing
Iraqis
me too Lockheed Martin said that they're
going to stop selling weapons to Israel
Saudi Arabia and the United States based
on an investigation into human rights so
so there's someone trolling here and and
at the at the end of the day you know
big Pharma already made a lot of profit
this is not gonna really hurt them and
it's not going to hurt them like they
hurt the American people that's right
look I was thinking about this uh
earlier one I really liked was from
Nestle it said we steal your water and
sell it back to you
no but what I was thinking is as I was
driving back from dinner I was just like
man this is really crazy all this
stuff's happening and then I was like
this is like the coolest thing ever yeah
it's it's just everything's been so
routine and so boring and these these
fake tweets because of Elon has resulted
in like a shock to the system this is
exactly what I've been talking about
Elon Musk threw a pie I've been saying
it's already figuratively throw that
right 15. yeah it's very it is
we're wrong it's not the Santa it's Elon
South African but he does get a lot of
money from the government but but what
he did here is is maybe Twitter
residence before haven't we sorry no oh
wait don't get don't go there but but he
did make Twitter very interesting and
this could be why there's allegedly
record users on the platform today
because it's it's so wild it's so crazy
I'm not losing that's the thing is that
Twitter's not losing users so we're
losing money yeah yeah well we will see
but
they might go to business Elon actually
said we may not survive the economic
downturn unless we get subscribers but
that was when he took it over no no this
was like a day ago no that's what I'm
saying
into a
fish yeah look what happens look at
what's happening with Facebook
sort of there's no the ad Revenue
stopped the big advertisers pause their
money oh right activists went and said
do it or else yeah elon's like we got to
fill that Gap with subscriptions and now
there's no they can't do that what they
might do is make it so that Twitter blue
verified accounts are the the only way
to see tweets and all non-paid accounts
will go into like a sub category that
you have to search for like you can we
were already there though I was a shadow
banned for 11 months it was crazy on
Twitter so like so so I was at 100 I
wanna I never wanted to be this guy I
mean I'm not a guy but I never wanted to
be this guy that's like whining about
their followers but I gotta say for 11
months I was at exactly
94.3 and it was only after I had hit
100K in less than a year so when you hit
that number something got triggered so
all of a sudden Elon buys Twitter and in
a week I'm back up over 100k yeah
I'll give you a simple version as to
exactly what happened
the reason Twitter was the Free Speech
wing of the Free Speech party was is
because it was operating on investor
cash they built up this big platform
making something fun and exciting then
the investors came and said when do we
get our return and they said we will
start selling ads they did The
Advertiser said hey we want to buy more
ads but you got a bunch of Nazis on the
platform and they said okay we'll ban
them then a bunch of actus activists
were like that conservative guy is also
a Nazi and they said okay we'll ban them
exactly they slowly started chopping
away at the Block trying to make
something they could sell to advertisers
killing the whole system in the process
in 2015 Twitter was on the verge of
shutting down completely people don't
know this it was about to go out of
business until Donald Trump signed up or
he was on that Donald Trump was already
there until he came in and started
tweeting up a kafifi and then all of a
sudden it was exciting ads were making
money again but Twitter had to keep
censoring because the activists were
screaming and the advertisers were
listening this is the best analysis I
think I've heard on on what actually
happened this is this is exactly what
happened that's that's pretty good and
so by that inside the company Jack
Dorsey is like we need to find a way to
make this work and so he promises me
years ago like we're going to create a
path to Redemption they never do and
it's because of this Elon comes in and
says I'm going to bring excitement back
to the platform and the advertisers
immediately jump ship now he says
they're burning four million dollars a
day
subscription is the only way to save the
platform or he should gut the whole
thing the video files should be done
through like BitTorrent or or
decentralization
I'll tell you you look at parlor gab
Mastodon there certainly not spending
four million dollars a day to operate
Elon could grind the whole company down
to a skeleton crew and make it a Bare
Bones text communication platform video
and photo can be hosted on other
platforms you can do a partnership with
Rumble that'll cut his costs way down
and that was
pretty on point are you on the showstop
or are you on the platform and how do
you like it uh so far uh well I tell you
what you know and when it when it first
started I was having a lot of fun
because there was just so many
ridiculous you know stupid cat memes and
and all kinds of fun stuff I mean I had
I had I was having a gas uh just clown
that's pretty much what I do now on my
on my side I try not to take it too
seriously because it's just it can get
too heavy life is so heavy as it is with
everything that's going on it's not for
serious you know so I so that's what I
attempt to do even if I'm making
political comments I try to do it in an
offhanded sort of way that hopefully
brings some some kind of sense of humor
to it rather than just like always just
being dark about everything you know I
hear you yeah the person I am on Twitter
I I believe or I hope is not the person
I am in real life like I've tried to
explain to people like how to have a
good Twitter account or whatever not
like I have some great Twitter account
but it's like
I I my way of saying it is um the worst
parts of my personality I save for
Twitter I'm like I'm actually a nice
person so people meet me in real life
and they're like oh like you're actually
like really nice and like not like like
because on Twitter all I do is shred
people but I shred people on my side
that's the thing if we're going to play
sides here politically I shred people on
the political right who are lying to
people I shred phonies that's my big
thing right like the other thing after
there's a lot of ponies out there yeah
and so like that's that's where I kind
of find my role because I don't work for
anybody and so everybody works for
somebody right like everybody thinks
they're going to come back into some
magical Administration or something like
that I am the boss like what am I gonna
fire myself so that's the one thing I
can give is to be truthful what what I
do on Twitter is I basically just uh
tweet the exact opposite of things yeah
that not for great no that's awesome 4D
Trump chess today oh no I said 12th
dimensional I know and then I said Trump
Trump's level of Chess playing is so
Advanced he surpassed M Theory it's very
esoteric M3 has 11 Dimensions Trump's
playing 12 dimensional chess but uh no I
I can't say exactly what I tweet not on
YouTube but that's the point is I
realize that if you tweet something
that's factual based on factual news and
a link to the news story the media will
twist the context of what you said to
make you look bad and they'll accuse you
of things you didn't actually do so this
uh election Integrity project or
whatever accused me of being one of the
biggest spreaders of like election
misinformation or something which is
totally false because I use newsguard
which is this like you know they did a
partnership with Microsoft for funding
and they fact check and so all the
stories I'm putting out are just basic
you know so then I realized okay all I
got to do is share the story and say the
opposite and then I win because now they
can't accuse me so I'll like if I see a
story that is shock talking to the
narrative that you know Biden commits
ex-crime I'll say this is clearly false
Biden would never do something like this
you are all crazy conspiracy theorists
that's how I operate on Twitter and uh
but some of the tweets are real so you
just you never know that's awesome and
that why that way if you're a journalist
you just have to ask me for a comment to
figure out which one's actually how I
feel or not there you go I'm just there
for the meme that's not bad the memes
are are I think a Lifeline to free
civilization that could actually save us
during these very difficult times but
but I always oh the Hat the hammer thing
has brought up some just memes that have
just been oh oh no they've been just so
funny I had to do that the hammer
wrestling match oh yes the the the pink
hammers
you insert batteries into yeah
um but that's again family friendly show
here I apologize here but it's not just
Twitter having difficulties here the
corporate media is now reporting that
Twitter was only able to get about a
half a million dollars from Twitter blue
itself that's some of the report
only half a million dollars was able to
be made off of Twitter blue According to
some corporate media like a day I mean
how long has it been allowed I mean it's
been out for today in total that's
that's
what
yeah one week that's half a million for
the whole month no no and they paused it
they paused it till Wednesday so it's
like literally been two days yeah but
you're saying still you're saying they
paid eight dollars everyone's paying for
a 30-day thing they've made half a
million dollars in 30 day subscriptions
and but they need four million a day
yeah so they need
300 million slow down it's been like two
days they pause it until Wednesday they
kicked it open if they made half a
million dollars within so it was like uh
I think it was I I think it was Tuesday
I was able to no no it wasn't it was
Wednesday they pause it for the midterms
and then Wednesday it went live and then
it was shut down early late last night
or early in the morning so it was barely
up last night barely up for two days and
he made half a million in subscriptions
they're gonna get that same half a
million again next month but fair point
they need 4 million per day because yeah
and when you're running still got magic
I mean when you're running a company
with thousands of employees he already
fired what was it a close to half of
them
we want him to be president too when he
said that remember when he was like and
he and they were they were they were
saying it was gut-wrenching uh uh lack
of emotion he just fired all these
people and I was like so when it was
Geraldo Rivera and I was like so what
you're saying is he should also be in
charge of personnel at the White House
well thank you finally someone who who
would have the Hoops about and the balls
to actually do something unlike someone
else but again that's another topic
don't want to go down that road uh but
no hold on a second but the corporate
media the corporate media was
gaslighting that all the Twitter
employees that were going to be fired
were going to go to Facebook Facebook
was going to steal all of these great
employees up literally that's what they
were saying That's how much they were
gaslighting people Twitter excuse me
Facebook is firing 11
000 employees they lost nearly and
that's just 200 billion dollars in just
one afternoon I don't think that's going
to be happening anytime soon and there
is something happening in the online
digital space that has advertisers
pulling away from Twitter even before
Elon Musk bought it which is another
perspective that people should
understand here
I don't think so centralized social
media should be used for profit anyway
you know
Communists like making roads so that I
can make money off of it and then me and
my little [ __ ] complaints which is no I
want to put video clips on I want to put
this on I want to do that because
yeah but Rummel I love Rumble but
Rumble has problems what problems I mean
technical problems well they owe me
millions of dollars to start with
because they've put uh ripped copies of
my movie up like every single day even
though I know the CEO I know the
Acquisitions guy I know every single
person over there and they can't get the
YouTube algorithm where you give YouTube
an imprint of your content and there
there can be no uh bootleg versions and
so it's like you know everyone who
claims the money for you or something or
a lot right exactly and so like well
well once well we're on YouTube like
we're on Google Play so it doesn't do
that but um and isn't that funny how
actually the only once we were on
YouTube meaning we were helping YouTube
make money did they do that for us for
the rest of the time we had to do phys
every single link had to be an actual
takedown
um but then and the best part is these
people would put it up and they'd be
like some a-hole named Amanda millius is
trying to take down plot against the
president she's probably a leftist
trying to keep us from the truth and I'm
like have you watched the credits it's
my movie I'm taking it down because it
cost money to make and they're like this
is so important you should just put it
out for free and you're like right that
that's right let's not build an industry
let's just let's make like subpar art
and just put it out for free that'll
that'll really take down Hollywood
that'll work
um our people are so stupid sometimes it
drives me nuts but they said the same
thing to Matt Walsh over what is a woman
oh for sure I'm sure they did you need
to release it for free and then we're
like why we're trying to we're trying to
make an industry I I I'm completely now
listen I get into it with daily wire
like all the time like I get into it
with Jeremy I get into it with Ben I get
into it we've known each other since
back in La I almost feel like it's to me
I don't take it too personally I'm just
like we're kind of like
you know rolling around like it's fine I
supported Matt Walsh's that movie quite
a bit because that was a very important
movie and I thought it was well you know
that was something I liked that they did
when I don't like something I say it
when I don't like something Dinesh does
I say it when I don't like something
like you know Steven Spielberg does I
say it because I went to film school I
like criticizing movies that's what I do
like it's not a big deal it's only they
take it so personally that they're just
like oh my god
um but yeah even on on stuff like that
like I understand why they have that
subscription model and why you just
described the Twitter subscription model
in such a way I mean it really is one of
these things where once you let in
advertisers you're letting in a sensor
board advertising is a censorship this
is this is why the same thing happened
we started pushing uh timcast.com trying
to build memberships to the website
that's why Infowars was the way is the
is the it only survives the way it does
and then they're even gonna go after him
this is the crazy thing because I get
hit up all the time by big networks
being like we should do a deal and we're
gonna give you yeah but this is fun
because these people they they and these
are Big networks these are Big networks
they seem to think I'm an idiot and
they're like why don't you do a deal
with us and we're going to pay you eight
figures we're gonna pay you all of this
money and I'm like oh yeah okay I know
what you're saying what you're saying is
you want me to read ads five times per
show that's right and then you'll make
eight figures take a cut off the top and
then give me dude we don't do that
because we don't want advertisers to do
contracts with us and then come back and
be like you know that last episode you
did we're not sure you know and then oh
no oh no we're gonna no no no we do a
handful of ads per month we do like six
and I'm like hey if you want to
advertise with us this is the show you
get we have Milo yiannopoulos the other
day you got a problem with it don't run
ads on our show that's how you have to
be but they I know that if I sign one of
these deals with any one of these
networks they would have said something
like you know we don't think you should
have Milo on because the current
advertisers that's exactly how it plays
out yeah
no become a member at timcast.com
I mean you're totally right about that I
mean that's the that's the reason that
like I'm you know you asked me a moment
ago or what's you know have you worked
on a movie since plot against the
president answer is no I'm building a
company the reason I'm building this
company is because I need a place where
the conservative
documentary and you know I'm working on
a couple of scripteds but that's just my
thing
um where the conservative world that's
going to do documentaries that would
normally just would crowdfund them and
just put them out on YouTube or put them
up for free on whatever
um that's their only way of getting
around the censorship is to not make
money but that's not an industry we're
not going to beat Hollywood without
being an industry which is why even when
I tussle with daily wire or I tussle
with Dinesh D'Souza who uses my movie as
a um as a search engine thing for his um
movie that did not as well
um all of that like that's fine that you
know I get it I'm sorry either you know
there's competition I would hate me too
if I was him um but but uh the the fact
is is that you're not gonna beat
anything you're not gonna be you're not
gonna create this free speech world if
you don't have a competitive industry it
is about the money we need to be able to
tell
high-level artist creatives we're gonna
pay you and and we're gonna pay the
investors investing in us we're work
we've got basically
their works and they're told by their
bosses they have to say woke stuff they
can say no they can come here because I
can go work for anyone but more
important not for those people jobs and
I don't have to and I can pay my
investors and that's the great thing is
that it's like like why and then you're
talking to these investors and a lot of
my investors are Republican donors I'm
gonna be that I can say and you're like
Okay cool so you're gonna let your money
on fire four times you know or every
every four years every two years and
um I get it it's a tax write-off or it's
a this or that or you're just
ideological or whatever it is but I'm
like I'm not asking you to donate I'm
I'm in you're investing in something
where I am one of three companies that
makes something for the entire United
States yeah and tell me about like how
is that not like the greatest deal ever
well more importantly people need to
understand that voting with your dollar
is sometimes more important than just
actually voting where do you put your
attention where you click what you watch
absolutely matters but you also have to
put the money where your mouth is and
again I used to rely on YouTube ads and
they used to limit my ads and then they
fully cut me off from the monetization
first yeah I was I was literally I was
like what the hell's going on here this
doesn't really make sense here we were
the first ones to get hit with this let
me put this into context for everybody
Luke you've been on YouTube since like
YouTube started 14 15 16 years there
didn't used to be demonetization nope
there was you had ads turned on our ads
turned off and I believe that we are
change was the first channel because
they would manually go in and turn the
ads off on your channel yeah without any
notification without any emails back on
yeah yeah I was like what what's going
on here and then no one knew what was
going on no one would get back to me We
snuck into a major YouTube party talk to
the head of monetization I don't know if
you remember that one when we stuck when
We snuck in with Casey neistat oh right
and I was there with the head of YouTube
monetization she's like I'm so sorry I
don't know what's happening here we're
going to figure this out for you don't
worry Luke we'll get back to the never
got back they were they were bad that we
were in there yeah they were like oh how
did they get it what do we do do we kick
them out yeah we literally stuck in
there it was hilarious it was it was
awesome it was a lot of fun what I'm one
of my own uh you know well memories but
I just wanted to say after they
demonetized me I was like script I'm
going to start a t-shirt company you
can't censor t-shirts in the real life I
started my own members area you can't do
that and it's only because of users
support that you're able to do what
you're you're you're doing so you're
able to do what you're doing and I'm
able to do it I want to explain to
people how easy it is so uh we went I
can't remember where it was it with
VidCon or something yeah I don't know
yeah no VidCon in uh California and so
we both knew people at YouTube I knew a
lot of people because I'd consulted for
Google and YouTube on live streaming
technology and mobile stuff and so when
we go up to where this party is I'm like
let's see what happens I see someone I
know from from YouTube and they're like
sorry it's like there's already a list
we can't let people in and I was like I
was like come on I was like we're here
you know who I am and they're like we
just can't cause like this capacity is
like okay there's a super exclusive VIP
party with a big list security guards
everywhere no one no one else is getting
in no matter what so so Luke and I walk
around the perimeter basically just like
taking a look at things trying to
because that's what you like figure out
what's going on and then we walk up to
the entrance and then we waited there
and then we saw Casey neistat walking in
with his Entourage and then we just
squeezed as close as possible to Casey
neistat and then he started yelling
about how they were like they stopped
him and they're like your friend can't
come in he's like what are you talking
about this is he's a big YouTuber and
then I'm like yeah you know like and
Luke is like what do you what do you
mean and then finally they're like okay
Casey we're so sorry you can bring your
people in he's like all right and then
we walked on him and then and then we
didn't have any wristbands or anything
and then we were like oh we need a
wristband we didn't get one there oh I'm
sorry and then get a wristband is that
easy yeah yeah that's that's if you're
meant to be there you will be there yeah
if you're persistent enough you could
get anything in life but but again like
if you just follow the old model if you
follow the old models and you don't
innovate you don't create your own
members area you don't create
merchandise you don't kind of think of
ideas out of the norm you won't make it
in this business because this business
is shutting down the door to anyone that
dares to question any kind of reality
yes and you just have to stay one step
ahead but again you gotta give the
credit to AJ on having done that back
before any of us I mean at least I don't
know about y'all well he he was doing
this before social media that's what I'm
saying and it's like and I remember that
episode to this day will always be
etched in my mind that episode he did
when
um
um Matt uh uh drudge showed up out of
nowhere and and did that episode and he
said start your own websites always have
your own form of income do not let them
put you in their little internet gulags
that's what they're going to try to do
and this was Matt drudge before whatever
happened to Matt drudge where he sold
the site or I don't know I don't know
what happened to Matt drudge but the
point is is like this this was this
episode it was in like 20 I don't know I
was in like film school so it must have
been like it was 2008 I think I was
warning in 2008 that there's going to be
censorship coming on this platform so
was that yeah and it was it was like it
was about but it was about exactly what
you guys were talking about where it was
like you have to stay ahead of the curve
innovate like sell other products
um have have your own website like have
your own member site have your own this
that they can't control do not depend on
YouTube do not depend always on just you
know Twitter social whatever social
media of the day was popular at that
time Instagram you can expect the
establishment to finance its own demise
and they won't ever do it you know a
good example that is I wanted to include
corn in this conversation and ask him
how the industry has changed as far as
monetization as far as money has you
have you noticed anything in the
industry yeah I mean I mean I was
thinking about that almost the whole
time uh that you guys were talking about
it because there there is a uh a shift
that hasn't happened yet and and I'm not
sure if if they really know how to make
it happen uh because the the box that
you're in in in the traditional way of
doing distribution
uh that that really comes with a lot of
control mechanisms like you were just
talking about you know there there are
certain parameters that you have to you
kind of have to why you can't create it
creatively in terms of yeah you know and
that but but then where where are you
going to take your your film your
original content and Market it to get
the same type of monetization potential
as you would get in home every single
platform so you take it that's the thing
you just it's just how you do the deals
this is what I that's the that is the
one thing I broke on plot against the
president that is the reason Amazon will
not take documentaries anymore but you
yeah documentaries are a different Beast
it's a different Beast than than
scripted content and stuff like that
especially when you're dealing with the
the all the genre specific issues and
stuff like that but but really it's
about platforming at the end of the day
there there isn't right now currently uh
that that I have found a really strong
distribution platform with direct
monetization for that for the films
where you're actually getting a
percentage of yeah every person right
away per view as it goes yeah every
person is a grifter well no every there
are a lot of grifters and every single
person that has I have met with that I
have sat with that was like we have a
platform and it's going to be for all
the people that are you know dissident
culture and it's going to be about not
censorship and it's this and it's that
it's some guy who literally is taking
somebody's money and running I have not
I have one Avenue that I think has done
this properly and it's rockfin rockfin
has a very good back end that's
trustworthy and is actually I believe
what they're telling me I've asked
somebody who has a film that is the
number one documentary to this day on
Amazon on all the different weird
platforms right because I want to try
all of them because I was like I got it
because eventually they're gonna come
for me they're not gonna let me put
something out I gotta know what's the
next big platform you're completely
right and I've been saying this for
three years I've been saying this at
every time I speak at uh at at certain
organizations that invite me to come
speak regarding platforms I say this
every single time you build me the
platform I will give you the content I
make content I don't make plastic yeah
so corn where do you see this going well
I mean what what I do see that's working
interestingly enough with with the Run
hide fight with daily wire and all that
is that I think that there's uh there's
an opportunity for a people who already
have built out platforms to use those
platforms themselves as a distribution
outlet for for scripted and you know but
then like five people see it no no
that's not true you're talking about
people who have millions of people
millions of followers on their platform
and the reach that that can go to from
there I think that that's one option
because otherwise it goes back to a
corporate you know a corporate style
eventually anyway when you have you know
platforms that are that are controlled
by corporate interests wait wait wait
wait we got breaking news we got
breaking news in Nevada Steve sisalak
has conceded to Joe Lombardo and the
Nevada's governor oh my God this is a
flip the state of Nevada has just
flipped to a republican Governor from a
Democrat it's been four years in Nevada
thank you you live in Nevada no I I've
worked on every campaign in Nevada that
exists I've been that's how I started my
political that is so how do you really
feel about it
what is the best time okay you guys just
like like I'm so that guy sucks so bad I
am so happy that Nevada is going red bet
on red guys bet on red do you want to
talk about that I want to talk about
this platform thing because I have an
idea so well let's let's chat about this
government black Salt's not looking good
it's it's tightening up so uh in Nevada
Adam laxalt is uh where are we at yeah
but it wasn't I it's uh it's down to
he's up by less than a thousand votes
like 700 800 yeah but the votes that are
coming in are continually skewing
Democrat he was up by a lot more and
it's getting Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter so they're actually I I really
he's he may call for a recount or file
he absolutely should 100 same thing with
Carrie like do not stop fight it until
finally they just say get out of the
courtroom especially in Nevada so last
election I did all I I was the last
person to leave I was the last one on
the last point out of Nevada that didn't
live there right that worked the
election not the RNC people who were
totally corrupt took the money and ran
the next day but
um Nevada is a place where I would
always do a recount always and the thing
is it's like it's not even possible
though because it's like
and I also want to add that Lauren
bobert is uh I'm not gonna think
it's basically one at this point Lauren
bobert's up uh 2000 about 1 000 just
just over 1 000 votes in Colorado's
third with 99 in so she probably won I
hope I mean you would think she's so
popular like to her people well but male
and mail-in voting again again 100 yeah
Democrats get people who don't know
what's going on to vote and their kids
whereas Republicans rely on people to
actively get up and go vote you have
something super difficult and that's why
what you just said actually really
matters and I get in arguments with
people about this all the time where
they're like oh who cares about the
culture I don't want to talk about the
culture War I just want to talk about we
got to talk about like the votes and the
elections today how are you meaning to
create the kind of candidates and the
kind of citizens that want to get up and
vote and vote for the type of candidates
that we need to have if you don't have
the culture element that stuff that's
why it matters so much I'm not saying
one's more important than the other
obviously I'm partial partial to culture
because that's what I do that's you know
but I also do politics so it's like yeah
without like educating your country
you're not gonna get the outcomes that
you want yeah I think you need the
technological element too and I to
piggyback off this conversation about
platforming and how distribution the
future of you know content distribution
I think about this I think the the
biggest problem one of the biggest
problems with content distribution is
piracy internet piracy where someone
will take your content and repost it
somewhere so if you could somehow have
content so that there's tags in it or
something that every time it's reposted
somewhere else it's still tracked back
to the Creator and you actually
encourage sites to Pirate contact and
sell it and you get a person you get 98
of the sale the site that sells it for
you gets two percent and then everyone's
going to be selling your art they're
gonna have websites of people selling
tens of thousands of movies for you
that's not dumb that is a smart way of
doing things and that needs that is
something that we need to look at
because it's not that I'm against
I mean look I I grew up not paying for
music I grew up not paying for all the
movies I've seen okay I get it I get it
but the problem is I have investors I
have people that I made a promise to
fiduciary duty
you can't just let this stuff out for
free yeah yeah yeah so if you but I
don't know if you can or if you make
terrible movies that go up on YouTube
that are like you know just what are you
doing made out of crap by myself yeah so
I agree I think that tracking I didn't
say a bad word
I'm doodling pictures tracking the money
is key and and if you could somehow
meditate the content itself like the
movie and then just a lot because piracy
is going to happen we can't stop it
I'm not even I'm just drinking coffee so
that's probably you don't have an excuse
It's the coffee what's in that coffee
you try it it's not it's nice it's
caffeine black I don't want it I'm
drawing I'm drawing I won't be able to
sleep Focus gotta drive me home
yeah but but by going back I mean I
think another another big issue that
that we run into is the is the marking
dollars how do you get you know how do
you get the attention that that you need
in order to drive traffic to whatever
whatever platform you're on make
something interesting you know well I
mean sure sorry that's the daily wire
speaker no no I mean tonight for
conservatives are you kidding me I think
almost all westerns were made for
conservative that's what I mean but uh
but that said uh you know I just think
that surely they can improve on the
genre I mean definitely I just did one I
just wrote one uh based on a graphic
novel that we just shot in New Mexico
with Stephen Dorff and Cole Hauser
starring and Jack Kilmer uh called dead
man's hand it's based on the same same
company that I gave you that comic book
uh rotten tail uh Source Point press did
a graphic novel uh come uh a western
dead man's hand that we just uh we just
finished shooting a couple weeks ago
actually have you experienced uh the
wokeness I mean I know earlier there was
talk about the pedophilia but there's
also the darkness in the industry which
is also a big issue you know I mean for
me I I just I I've been on my own path
in the industry since day one really I I
growing up in the industry I was a
graffiti artist before I was an actor
and I kept hanging with all my all my
buddies that I grew up doing graffiti
art with what was your hand hanging out
my first one my first one was Chrome uh
k-r-o-m-e I got caught in 10th Grade
because me and my buddy Dapper were
tagging high schools and Junior highs on
Sunday nights so that everybody would
see our our get-ups on Monday morning it
was a great way to get up but uh and
then I then I switched over to Pike
which is uh which is something that I
still use I still paint were you in L.A
but yeah yeah I grew up in Las Vegas
where did you go to High School uh North
Hollywood High no okay were you there
too Amanda yeah that's one way to get
motivated to go to school yeah
indoctrination centers they're going to
call the schools oh man yeah North
Hollywood High we had back in the 80s we
had you know they used to put chains
around the doors when Once school
started in the morning and lock you in
from the outside and we had barbed wire
fences 12 foot high all the way I was
like going to prison every day for you
know five six hours but uh but it was
safe it was predominantly safe no man
people got knifed shot beaten with pole
I saw a guy's shoulder get collapsed in
the quad and we had full-blown riots and
uh it was insane man it was absolutely
insane going to the in the 80s the gang
wars of the 80s and everything else and
uh it was it was a wild time no doubt
dude make a movie about that I want to
see that they did a couple times I went
to school in the 90s in New York City
and again metal detectors when you walk
in craziness I can't even imagine you
can't even just we had we had lap or
they still do I'm sure but we but in the
80s we had LAPD on campus so you had
like principal assistant to principal
Dean assistant Dean LAPD we had two
armed police officers on campus every
day we had a cop that drove around
campus all day long and steel people got
shot and stabbed and beaten and
everything else
Chicago was just walking down the street
people started shooting at each other
yeah
sometimes it's because the gangs will be
like just kill that person to prove
you're you're yeah that was going on in
the 80s a lot of assassinations though
they'll say like this guy they target
you know yeah yeah
um well I guess we could move on topics
but just to cap off this talk about
distribution models you were saying that
marketing money you said that the key is
well that I mean it's it's it's a it's
about driving traffic how do you get how
do you get the eyeballs on on some
content that you're trying to
independently platform without a big
distribution or or major uh film company
behind you or backing you you know so
there is a model to be able to do it but
where is it going to be platformed
that's the thing and how do you get the
money directly so you know are you are
you charging per view on the platform
people go in is it I mean what what is
it it's not there yet it doesn't exist
yet you know so I I am interested in in
the future of platforming but uh you
know of of original content but right
now I have to go with the old model I
mean I'm doing Lifetime movies for
Lifetime channel writing and producing
them and and they're very specific genre
oriented they're sold there they're sold
to tf1 in France they're they're
guaranteed certain sales and all that so
the profit margin is locked in for the
investors and you know and and if one of
them escapes and does better than it's
expected to great but you know the
protection for the investor and and for
everybody else involved creatively is
doing these these specifically genre
films uh you know that that are
guaranteed a certain a certain sale uh
on the front end because a lot of
distribution companies they promise you
a back end that you never get because I
don't want to live like that though see
that's the thing is like I I you're
right you are correct that is the model
that's the the tried and true model that
they taught us at school that's been
going on since forever but I think I had
a win doing it my way absolutely and I
want to keep pushing that envelope
because I I can't like announce what the
idea is for the next thing because then
it won't work right because I just told
everybody what it was but I I think I
can break the machine and I want to
break the machine because you shouldn't
have to do that you shouldn't have to be
like stuck in this I I know exactly what
you're talking about I just did Cam this
year for the first time yeah and it was
the most like depressing gross
experience of like walking around in
every single country made the same six
movies yeah yeah you're like this is not
like the home of Cinema not to mention
like like the obsession with the Ukraine
where you you would think that like the
Ukrainian film had been like the
Cornerstone of European Cinema for a
hundred years
um it was so bananas but uh yeah I I
like I think I'm in a position that I
can
smash that and I I don't disagree with
you what you're describing is the model
and like yeah I just I just don't want
to listen yeah there's a way to break
the mold there's a way to break them
well I think it's easier with
documentary because documentaries have a
different lasting they have a different
shelf life than you know
I mean that's the thing is we have a we
have a we have literally half the
companies docked half the company
scripted yeah and like I don't yeah so
I've been in the Grassroots you know
putting it out there and getting it on
this platform and then you find another
platform and then another one and
another I think I fixed the PRL element
yeah I'll tell you what it is after okay
cool I look forward to it um Amazon you
got to get me into that that Mason that
that big thing near my place
I think I think women are not allowed
into yeah
they have George Washington's
um kind of freemasonics
did the Jews run everything or is it the
Masons because the Masons don't let you
in if you're Jewish or so that's not
true or this is uh this is that's true
Battlestar Galactic so you're telling me
you guys know you guys know what ship
this is this the ship do you know what
the ship is no from Battlestar Galactic
it looks like Kestrel I don't know I
don't know exactly what it is it was a
gift but have any of you seen Lord of
the Flies have any of you have any of
you read or seen one before no okay this
is the comment you can only talk if
you're holding it I like it
I'm having a panic well I Won't Say I'm
having a bit of a panic no but I think
the the viewers are starting to complain
a whole lot so how about you hold the
spaceship and you can start talking
about your ideas uh well this I mean you
said Lord of the Flies I just have to
give a shout out to Balthazar Getty then
because that's one of my old my me and
him were best friends growing up
together and that was his first film he
did a great job as you know as the lead
in that uh what this is fantastic you
know I'm distracted I love models I love
Miniatures and stuff so this is just I I
can look at this all day yeah I'm all
about it I know I forgot what we were
talking about oh I don't know should we
talk about something yeah let's talk
about stuff it makes sense
whatever you guys want well the Mason
conversation is pretty good let's talk
about that what's going on with that
Mason stuff
um well for me I mean I you know I've
been interested in in kind of the
conspiracy theories and stuff like that
my since I was a teenager and uh my when
I found out that you know Freemasons
were the Illuminati and all of this I
was like wait a second my grandfather
and great-grandfather were both Masons
and they sure as hell weren't involved
in any kind of weird racket like that
and uh uh so I got more interested in
the philosophical side of it and reading
you know some some Masonic books and
literature uh and and came to realize
that it's it's it's more of a a
principled philosophical way of thinking
and and and applying uh analogies uh
kind of you could say construction
analogies to life really you know um but
uh so I I got interested in it from that
from from that aspect and then when I
got into my 20s joined a lodge in San
Antonio perfect union Lodge Number 10
around 1997 and did my three primary
degrees uh up through uh you know the
year 2000. yeah I mean uh you know
Freemasonry is is you know a lot of
people call it a secret society uh so
obviously you can't talk about some of
the secrets so what are some of the
secrets
you talk about anything like that the
only thing you can't you can't discuss
are just the the actual initiation
rights and and the dialogue that's used
in the initiation were you able to meet
any kind of like prominent people uh
through it there's been I mean I I I've
been to the Grand Lodge in London a
number of times to the Tea Room there
and and there's definitely some pretty
interesting folks that were hanging
around there but uh uh but uh oh you
know overall my my interested in it is
is purely philosophical and fraternal uh
I I really enjoy traveling the world and
going to other lodges and meeting other
brothers who have the same kind of you
know philosophic mindset and and
curiosity yeah I know like Shaquille
O'Neal is also like a Freemason there's
a lot of other prominent people that are
also Freemason yeah Prince Hall lodges
are are huge they're very very active uh
if I'm I'm pretty sure that I'm correct
that he's in in Prince Hall Lodge which
uh I have a number of good friends and
is it true that they all go back to the
ideology who was it who invented uh
Freeman's Freemasonry in the United
States was it Albert Albert Pike no
Albert Pike introduced Scottish rights
masonry uh after uh the Civil War which
which I'm really not into I think that's
more of the the side that sort of is is
where the illuministic side kind of
comes from and to me I think they sponge
off the blue Lodge and by this thing of
offering more light you know so oh
there's 33 degrees or 32 degrees degrees
of the with the 33rd being a bestow
degree a bestow degree but you know they
keep offering more light more degrees
more this and there's just nothing to it
it's it's you know the three primary
degrees are the the most Sublime and
that's where you're going to get your
you know your aha moment what's a degree
well that's the those are the the three
uh the three initiations that you go
through in blue Lodge uh Entered
Apprentice fellow craft and Master Mason
uh and each one has kind of a different
uh a different series of working tools
that they're based on and also uh you're
you're going kind of through a death and
Resurrection uh um you know uh
the death of Resurrection ideology like
where you're you're letting go of your
old self and opening up to the
possibility of being able to recreate a
whole new uh life for yourself as a new
person based on you know from the ground
up I mean you can let go of everything
that you've known from the past have a
clean slate and then recreate yourself
from that point forward do you do the
degrees like classes do you take classes
or is it some like is it just like work
you have to have a mentor because
there's no way you can do the degree
work alone because you work with
somebody else in the in in the actual
initiation it's a q a back and forth
basically I do have to read a lot of
books and then you have to go through a
specific ritual to get to the next level
and then sometimes the ritual is like a
test and sometimes you pass the test and
sometimes you don't right yes it will
and that's and that has to do with the
whole q a thing it's you know there is a
performative value to it and and and
what you learn from from what you
memorize and and how you respond and if
you don't have all of this stuff uh um
down to a t that and you won't get
passed on to the next degree you have to
repeat that again and again and again
until you get it right and the more that
you read and understand about it then
it's you know the better off you are for
sure can I just ask one thing about it
how does it comport with a belief in God
you have to have a belief in God to be
amazing because the the Bible is is the
light of masonry and and if but if
you're a Muslim and you're you're a mace
and then it would be the Quran or if
you're a Jew and you're a Mason then it
would be the Old Testament versus the in
the inclusion of the New Testament on it
or if you're Hindu then it might be The
Vedas or every single Lodge would
potentially have a different gnosticism
where it's like based in like the
luciferian idea of like absolutely not
the highest form no absolutely not okay
no no no that that and uh I mean I I
wouldn't say I mean in having read about
the the cathari and the albigensians and
all that I would never necessarily even
say that narcissism has that as its
fundamental belief either but uh I I
think it has more to do with the
enlightenment of the of the human soul
and the and and the you know the raising
of of oneself to a higher uh uh
experience of Consciousness I've always
found gnosticism makes a lot of sense in
that it just kind of stands for like the
knowledge that you have is The
Enlightenment like the processes the
enlightenment is that Blasphemous to
people of of churches to say that
gnosticism is awesome I mean well most
of the Catholic church because the uh
their Crusades were against the Gnostic
the second Crusades were against the
gnostics and they went and all
throughout southern France and Spain and
murdered them by the tens of thousands
and and uh traditionally there there's
there's a uh through a line of theory
that ties narcissism to the original
teachings of Christ and the original
practicing the practices of of the of
the true Christians uh before the uh the
the the Christianity was usurped by the
Roman uh Catholic Church which was
previous to that mithraism they they
were it was a a you know a pagan type
belief system which Pagan is not even a
correct term for because until they got
obsessed with the Jew in Jerusalem and
then does it doesn't Solomon plays a key
factor yeah I was just going to say I
literally just wrote Solomon's Temple I
was like doesn't this go all the way
back until the Knights of Templar
Solomon's Temple and allegedly the
secrets that they found there and they
used that kind of secrecy to allegedly
fight against the pope right is am I
correct because I remember studying this
like years and years and years ago but
they said that he found they found the
treasure they said they said you know
that was the theory is that the Knights
Templar uh either found some old
manuscripts or or actual Treasures or
things like that that they then brought
back to Europe and and and they were
able to you know expand their the you
know the Knights Templar as an order uh
it drastically because of this knowledge
or whatever it was that they they got a
hold of which is still a mystery to this
day I've played Assassin's Creed it was
a alien technology wasn't it makes sense
I haven't played Assassin's Creed but
I'm familiar with what you're talking
about I love the movie
yeah I I think I've seen I I don't know
if I remember the movie but uh in the
first couple of games it was the secret
for like the the progenitors of Earth
aliens and like the Apple was like some
powerful object what's really
fascinating about it is that the symbols
are everywhere the the kind of is it
sacred geometry or is it just because
you look at architecture you look at
corporate logos you look at almost
anything of prominence you look at the
landscape of how Washington DC is built
yes it's all it all comes it's all built
on freemasonic kind of architecture
which is weird also yeah and also
allegedly unlike uh Power Ley lines as
well yes that's true but but really all
of that comes out of the tree of life
the the kabbalistic tree of life and and
the pattern the pattern that it's made
and all of all of the different symbols
come out of that when you when you uh
the the Star of David and the
interpretation of the Tree of Life
it's the actual connection of all of the
different uh the the connection lines
between the cephodot uh you know so you
have the 10 several you have and you
have all of the the connection points
between them and from all of those
connection points the symbolism comes
out of it and that goes into the sacred
geometry of of fractaling and everything
else so it's it's uh it's certainly all
of those symbols certainly do come out
of the tree of life but the tree of life
itself comes out of an even more Sublime
symbol and doesn't it take it down to
like how the human body is constructed
absolutely yeah the tree of life is laid
right on top of the human body you can
you can you can you can tie that in with
with the chakraic systems uh you know
it's it's the they're identical they've
just they've just split them uh on the
Tree of Life they've split they've split
several of them into Dynamic polars but
when you combine them all together it's
the same seven to nine chakras that you
generally find in in a normal system but
you can understand sounds like a lot of
stuff that Ian's talking about you had
fractals and the the aligned chakras I
think I saw Ian's eyes like a little bit
more traditionally like you have to
understand that it's not it's not that I
I uh like disagree with obviously I know
nothing about the Masons compared to you
but like I'm Jewish right so like I I
may not be as on board with my religious
symbolic you know symbols being
utilized in another
theologies philosophies well I'm Jewish
too so yeah but that would I could say
the same thing about you know things
I've seen in Evangelical churches or
things like it's like you know what I
could I could whine about her all day
long I mean in fact you could you could
talk about the Old Testament the New
Testament but we use I'm happy it's like
we use Hebrew and we use Hebrew letters
and all of that in in Freeman in Fremont
in Freemasonry when I first saw a
Freemason book I thought it was Hebrew
right is it based off the Kabbalah or is
it well it's involved it's involved it's
involved because I mean and that goes
that goes way back because you also have
to think uh you know that in in the
practicing of of those kind of uh of
that type of magic if the Knights
Templar were involved in in practicing
kabbalistic magic that would be
perceived as witchcraft and and other
types of things
but ignacius Loyola the founder uh you
know the founder of the illuminata in
the 1500s was practicing Kabbalah and
that's who you know and that's where the
Illuminati comes from in Bavaria by Adam
weishau who was also a Jesuit priest who
was picking back up where ignacio's
loyal Loyola left off back in the 1500s
so yeah but like as a Bavarian Jew
that's how I feel every time you talk
about movies or video games
like all I'm saying is like it just
gives me a little bit of
trying to like to like not have the
world come kill you like you know what I
mean like as a Jew just like in general
uh as as does happen like once every few
hundred years or sometimes more often
um where you're just like
magic and this and that and then I'd be
like I'm just into God like like old old
testament old school would you say you
guys are practicing Magic
uh well everybody is everything is
magical there's there's nothing around
us that isn't Magic every time we're
we're trying to explain something to
somebody as soon as they understand our
communication to them we've performed a
spell because now they're thinking with
our information so there's nothing that
that we're not doing that isn't magical
in essence this table is Magic it wasn't
once a table it was a tree that was then
brought down it was carved changed you
know uh cars how what a car is a magic
item you know what I mean it's been it's
been milled from from the ground of
taking ore and molten metal and crushing
it and then shaping it and then putting
it together and then something you put a
chemical into it and start it up and
boom it can drive that's magic I mean
we're surrounded by Magic everybody's
practicing magic I love the metaphor of
casting a spell and when you make words
you spell them yeah the word spell
that's 100 that's where it comes from
what's uh what what makes you want to
become a Mason what do you what do you
get from it be it emotional physical or
what um well I mean initially I did it
because my family you know and and and
but once I real you know that that was
what my my my attraction was to it but
uh but really what it is is it's it's a
system with which you're you're taught
very it's It's oddly It's oddly complex
but very simple at the same time you
know it's it's it's a it's allegories
and uh and and symbols that once you
understand them they they can they
freeze in the mind and you can access
them very easy it's it's it's a
psychology really it's kind of a
psychology so why not publish it
regularly and make it more accessible it
is there's loads of books uh all about
it it's just nobody buys them nobody's
interested and nobody masonry is open
it's just that yeah the only thing
that's closed about masonry is just the
just the initiation process everything
else is wide open all the books are out
there the the the the Insight there's
free Masonic encyclopedia sets that you
can get there's I mean you name it you
can get it the only thing you can't get
is is access to the actual initiation uh
ceremony unless you join but at the same
time you can even get that information
out there now there's there's books that
where they where they've taken uh you
know our code books and and uh they've
translated them and they've put them out
there to the public it's all accessible
so why is there so many connections
between like
um Masonic imagery and what we've come
to learn about
um
Satanic rituals and luciferian stuff is
that just the same sort of thing as like
you know what I'm kind of arguing
against which is like you know
frequently like ah the Jews run
everything blah blah blah well is that
the same kind of music or is it yeah
it's the usurption of the symbolism by
by illuminous like the black and white
floors and the two columns and the whole
thing like that well all of that see
that you're gonna have opposing uh
meanings for them by by different groups
so so the see for instance illuminism
Adam weishop they're they're they're
they're they're their sole goal was to
infiltrate and take over Freemasonry and
introduce illuminism into the rights and
practices of Masons so the in in in
essence when when you have the Golden
Dawn for instance and and others
quasi-masonic orders that that come out
of masonry they're taking the Masonic
symbolism with them and then they're
yeah and then they're turning it on its
head so suddenly you're looking at
you're looking at a the Golden Dawn
going oh they're using the same eye and
in the pyramid and they're using the
same this and that and oh that's got to
be Mason suit no it's not it's it's not
that's how I got introduced to that
stuff that's why I get heebie-jeebie
about it is because when I was in
college I accidentally went to this
totally bizarre communist college and
ins like I just tried to avoid their
protest classes and I took a Yates class
and it was just Golden Dawn like just
the whole time and I was just like I
didn't sign up for Satanism like this is
most of the most of the founding fathers
were Freemasons yeah that's the blue
Lodge that's the standard that's a
standard three three degrees
it's you know that's that's the founding
that's the that's the foundation that
that all all the other masonic sex are
based on so so even York right which has
uh I believe uh six degrees you know you
have to do the first three to get you
know to go up those you know and same
with Scottish Rite you can't get into
Scottish Rite unless you've already done
the blue Lodge degrees
you know so it's it's really the it's
the Bedrock was it just like a uh but
like a way of teaching and learning and
knowing like if you're a Mason then you
know these things I don't have to worry
about you not understanding 100 I view
it you're saying there's a lot of like
mechanical metaphors involved yeah I
mean well for instance the 24 inch gauge
which is used obviously used in
construction for for measuring you know
uh you know you use that to break up
your time uh into three eight hour
segments one for work one for rest one
for recreation uh you use the the uh the
the square encompasses the compass to to
keep your uh desires within due
circumference you use the Square to
Square your actions uh you use the the
level to remain upright you know uh all
of these you know all these analogies
you apply to the self and you and you
are the Mason and the edifice that
you're building is in the mind this gets
into Solomon's Temple is that there that
in in Freemasonry there's a there's a
strong belief that the that the first
temple was never built that it was only
built in his imagination and that it was
never actually built in physical reality
uh so you know it's about the temple
that we're building in our minds and
then into reality Let's uh
let's let's jump into something else
let's jump into the story of The Daily
Mail this is crazy I saw this story it
was amazing
let's go
let's talk about another story from the
Daily Mail in this story I was surprised
to see it Mexico uses footage of
homeless people and drug addicts from
Philadelphia in advertisements to scare
young people away from substance abuse
awesome these images are are saddening
now did they bring the the
philadelphians to Mexico to shoot this
or do they go on location to
Philadelphia I think they probably just
pulled the videos from social media from
Kensington Broadway yeah they just I
mean this is this is insane oh it's
insane it's just completely I think
that's it right there you can just watch
that oh wow there it is hey that's a
nice production value yeah they're girls
lovely I mean she's cute
oh no she's on drugs in Philadelphia
Street people great account to follow
skateboarding
wait what is this is that this is what
you should be doing is what they're
saying skateboarding not doing drugs in
Philadelphia and they're not wrong and
Mexico is winning with that one well
they don't have any drugs left in Mexico
they're all they're all here but what's
the point of selling them in Mexico and
you can't charge 50 times for them then
you can hear filter the fentanyl from
China through our open border and kill
everybody here I mean that's what people
don't understand is that China has a 50
100 year long memory I mean a 250 year
long memory and a hundred year long plan
and they're still pissed about the Opium
Wars and we don't understand that and
everyone's like why does China keep
sending their fentanyl here and we don't
do anything about it they should be
sending it to the UK I mean we didn't
have anything to do with it
the thing about what's going on right
now in the United States is that we had
the economy completely destroyed I often
was asking where did everybody go how
come we went to we were in New Market
Virginia last weekend and the restaurant
had a big old white board that said we
are understaffed please be patient
nobody wants to work anymore and then
Ian you actually hit the nail on the
head with the hammer I think when I
started making the joke that people were
raptured you just said I think they're
homeless and then I was like oh my God
yeah actually yeah because
while we're seeing employment collapse
for for lesser skilled and lower skilled
jobs we're seeing homelessness and drug
abuse Skyrocket there's probably a
correlation right it's been happening
quietly
it's only quiet because they're not
they're ignoring it it's being
completely ignored it's you know it's
it's I mean how often do you see any of
this information on but that's what they
want you know in Mexico some of the
cartels have very strict rules where you
can't give fentanyl to the local
population you get punished you there's
retribution in the streets if you give
out the drugs that are supposed to go up
north if you give it out to the local
population because they know the
devastation that it would cause the
local population and how horrible
horrible it would be this is also as of
course there's also a very mirrored uh
history between a lot of the cartels and
American intelligence agencies working
together historically that have been
shipping in things like crack cocaine
and it wouldn't surprise me well it
wasn't in crack form when they shipped
in it
yeah yeah well the CIA taught people how
to do this
that's how the clintons elbow their way
into a CIA family because when people
don't realizes that the Obamas and the
bushes have much more in common than the
clintons and the bushes the clintons and
anyone else is that those are old school
CIA families like in if you want to make
sorry Mason reference their 33rd whereas
like the clintons are like nine like the
clintons are like down here elbowing
their way up into the higher level CIA
like thinking they're going to have a
legacy they're not and then there's a
big history in Amina Arkansas that's
what I'm saying you know Arkansas is
what happens when um is is what Clinton
agreed to run in order to become
president I mean basically there's a lot
of people that think that this is a meme
it says breaking Elon Musk has
reportedly made an offer to buy the FBI
from the clintons oh awesome do it
that's a good news I think it's like my
most like post too because it has 48 989
likes just post more memes whenever you
post a meme it's like I get tens of
thousands of likes and I'll post
something like about my life and like
everyone's like Tim we don't care about
you yeah yeah yeah
the only one we're only there for the
memes man I yeah these are great this is
a good one though this was this was a
good one so yeah I don't know man when
you look at what's happening with our
elections
it it's you know I think a lot of people
are really angry Milo pointed out they
wanted uh Revenge they were hoping that
this would be an absolute National
rebuke of the Democrat failures instead
we ran the same play we got a win you
know that's that's it in the house and
it's not even confirmed just yet and I'm
kind of just like I don't know I was
thinking about what Michael malice was
saying with John fetterman getting
elected and how he wanted him in and I
thought it was kind of funny so you know
the more I think about it this is a
product of absolute collectivism and I'm
very much more on the side of
individualism so my worst case scenario
is we go anarcho libertarian or whatever
it's not my ideal circumstance I know
the anarchists and Libertarians are
probably loving if a system breaks down
and collapses they're going to be
they're going to be living large but I
can I can live with that I can deal with
that if that's what happens you know
what I mean weird you and my dad have
like that that are like those guys I'm
that guy I'm like this is music to my
ears hell yeah let's do it let's bring
Tehran to the United States I've learned
to accept it and to learn like to
embrace the Zen anarchism like and to
even try and understand what it is like
I have I have only now begun to have
like thrive in the chaos kind of vibe
but like uh it still is I have to say
like at the end of the movie I made it's
sad I mean it's I I was I inherited this
country it's the only thing I would die
for if not my family so I'm not really I
don't feel bad bad being genuine about
this like a lot of these people these
days like after this election like
there's a lot of I won't mention who but
there's a lot of like irony going around
where it's like don't you know elections
are fake anyways like anybody who took
this seriously is dumb and you're like
no actually I I really care about my
country and I don't mind saying so like
it's really important I think what's
also happening here in America with a
lot of these drug overdoses is something
that has been adding to the larger
political shift in this country because
when you look at the opioid epidemic it
predominantly went after Middle America
it went after people that weren't in the
cities people who trusted their doctors
got in a car accident and their doctor
said hey take legalized heroin that
we're gonna cut you off immediately and
now hey now you got to go through Mexico
now you got to go through the cartels
now you gotta go through your local
drugs to get hooked criminalize it and
when you criminalize it you create a
situation where uh of course there is
more harm and more people are dying from
bad drugs more than ever more gang
members are becoming more enriched more
than ever and it's a situation
deliberately created in my opinion meant
to devastate Middle America and this has
been seen as a result of of eliminating
a lot of would-be Republicans
yes and what is the why is that why
would they want to do that because you
will be happy right because people
depended on Government Can you have they
don't want people that are ungovernable
that's why we see authoritarianism in
extremely poor countries because when
you're worried about what to eat and
what you're going to feed your family
you don't have time to have time-minded
philosophical conversations about what
political system you're going to have
and that's the problem with the right
too I was just having a meeting with
somebody earlier today and you're like
like like like we're talking me and this
girl are basically on the complete same
side we're talking about it like we're
on totally opposite complete political
sides we're on the right and it's like
we like take our minds most minute
differences and we make huge issues out
of them and it's like well I can't go
along with this because of X Y and Z and
it's like that the left doesn't do that
the left is just like they're coming
after abortions go vote
and you're like uh like why can't like
it's like but they don't vote for
anything Democrats vote because someone
knocked on the door and said vote they
went oh gosh Karen are you in California
no I live in Florida have you started
there you go I live in Florida too
it's awesome but incredible but but even
in Florida you do see this this larger
impact of this kind of uh this kind of
destruction of our society have you seen
it in your experiences I mean uh
especially with my son and uh my son 17
and uh lives out in the suburbs of
Houston
um and that uh I can tell you the you
know they had they've had a number of
incidents they've had a number of kids
at his school who've all died from
fentanyl overdoses and not because they
knew it was fentanyl because they
thought they were taking an ecstasy
that's right or they thought they were
taking something else because they're
pill pressing these things uh what now
whether they're pill pressing the
fentanyl into these forms and saying
that it's something else and and and not
intentionally putting an overdose amount
in there or intentionally putting an
overdose amount in there I I can't say
for sure but the fact that it's in there
at all is frightening remember when the
U.S government put I think it was
methanol was that in the alcohol when
yeah yeah that was a short-lived
short-lived stun people started dying it
was a short-lived yeah they killed
people the government deliberately
killed people they were violating
prohibition I was here
methanol methanol I'll tell people that
you methanol means you'd be blind I'm
pretty sure or dead uh no but so so hold
on hold on we'll clarify the you you
what the government was hoping was that
by putting methanol and alcohol nobody
would drink it yeah exactly yeah and
then people drank it and they died and
thought okay we're gonna stop doing that
no no they wanted a story where people
would die from it they would run with
those headlines seeing see bootleggings
dangerous you you better not drink the
bootleg alcohol
yeah literally created uh you know
mafias mafias wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for government prohibition now
exactly there you go
I was waiting to argue and I was like
that's actually a good point there
that's a great point it sends ancient
Rome in some form or another but they
became as prominent and as powerful only
because for sure that's what happens
the point is the government is a mafia
period there you go and then
they're organized structures like you
know people people uh have this like
um I guess fictionalized view of what a
mafia is where they're like purely
antagonistic to the community and
they're not the same thing is true for
gangs people people that's actually true
gangs are antagonistic in fact when I
went Brazil and Chicago is a really
great example the gangs in Chicago were
not overtly antagonistic we go to the
park and we'd be like oh look there's a
bunch of people from a gang and they
were just a gang and they would do stuff
and in fact they would police their
neighborhoods yeah so when when people
felt like they weren't being protected
and they didn't have the same access as
other people in terms of public
resources or industry they created their
own that's what people do they form
organizations
now some of these people that's what
happens with communities do uh but all
communities do it the difference is the
United States we've we've Mass scaled it
up to the point where it's surrounding
the nation and with military bases all
over the world when I look at uh Brazil
Brazil was a really great example of
this with with the favelas when the
government wasn't active in the shanty
towns The favelas Gangs came up and
became the de facto leadership when the
government realized hey there's tax
money we need to get this stuff we need
to modernize and take control of it they
had to quote unquote pacify meaning they
would go in and rip apart the gangs and
then reassert their dominance over this
area but the gangs were basically just
local government yeah when you say rip
apart you mean they would kill people oh
yeah that's the only way to do it
that's right FBI application rating the
the homes and rating the political
opposition you have to realize that the
FBI is just the gang of the party of the
regime right now they're after the
aliens yeah they're after the UFO guy
yeah I rated today which is absolutely
insane but it's just like a real thing
like yeah it actually happens I want to
talk about this about what the UFO today
it's not the guy who like wrote Behold a
pale horse or something is it no they
took that guy they took that guy down
yeah
that's right
that's right yeah that's right what was
that I wrote I read the article where
William Cooper former US Navy I read his
article I read his article that uh when
it came out in in 1999 actually uh uh I
forget the magazine that it was in one
of these alternative Maps
he died in a shootout with police yeah
well in one a One Direction shootout
sort of like Waco
yes Milton William Cooper yeah former
U.S naval intelligence a crazy book that
he wrote the whole house yeah
he died November 5 2001. so that's short
to just about two months after 9 11.
yeah what does he keep talking about was
he like it's a conspiracy I did not know
oh yeah he was on he was addicted he
predicted it yeah so to what degree like
what did he predict
um you could you I I gotta watch the
video just to make the exact reference
here because I don't want to be very
careful with how I say it but uh do you
remember the exact references yes well
he did on his radio show he he uh he
talked about it and and but it wasn't so
much in the sense that I mean he if I
recall correctly
yeah so did Alex Jones but before Alex
Jones it was William Cooper I believe
yes yeah yeah and there was also we were
talking about Jordan Maxwell earlier
there was another guy who was who was
really on onto all of this stuff and
everything but but that's uh but that
was uh that was pretty shocking but it
was it was in such a way that he didn't
say specifically what happened but you
know I would have to go back and look at
it again as well but it was uh it was
pretty eye-opening yeah
wrote a book about his case where it
included an entire chapter about
um Osama Bin Laden that was removed from
later printings
he said Osama Bin Laden will be blamed
for it I think that's one exactly yeah
before 9 11. do you want the comments
let's just just absolutely segue into
something totally unrelated that's the
whole show this is uh Richard medhurst
says this is huge over a dozen
you're done yeah keep going
but I still think you need
more than I do go go
this is huge all right so we have a
tweet here from Richard medhurst says
this is huge over a dozen countries have
now applied to join bricks including
Algeria Iran and Argentina the
multi-polar order is taking shape before
us if expanded bricks would compromise
over half the global population 60 of
global global gas and 45 of global oil
reserves to me it doesn't sound like
multipolar it just sounds like the end
of America sounds like bipolar is what
it sounds like no no it's the end of the
United States it is the Pedro dollar
yeah yeah it'll be it'll be the death of
the Petro dollar no doubt I mean I hate
to say this but this is what I was
talking about on the last show like no
that the the end of America being a
superpower like people aren't really
ready for that but it's not it's they
don't know what it's like to not be in a
country that can just flip a switch and
say I want things Tim do you know are
they doing are they doing an actual
currency with this or is it is it just I
mean are they going to launch a currency
that's going to back this up I bet it'll
be a crypto
when they were doing uh when the EU was
first launching they were selling it was
I think it was five cents on the dollar
you could buy the Euros before they
launched the before they fully launched
I I if this if they're gonna make a
currency out of this I want it
yeah there's a news article from October
7 2022 their Putin said he plans on
creating a quote new Global Reserve
currency yeah it's going to be a central
bank digital currency and I would be
willing to bet you know I'm not saying
it's true I'm saying it's hyper
speculative highly speculative but I
would not be surprised if American
Elites are purposefully tanking the U.S
while sending their assets over through
maybe like Panama where a lot of money
was stored or Switzerland and and and we
know uh Joe Biden flew on Air Force two
with his son Hunter to for a private
Equity deal in China I think the elites
they are they are stealing the
silverware from the Titanic after the
iceberg was hit 2008 they're jumping
telling everybody everything's fine
don't worry about it taking those
lifeboats off to another big ship
loading up all this over coming back and
saying everything's okay people don't
worry about it they're getting ready to
jump ship
I would buy that
the Ukraine uh the Ukraine business and
I explain I think that explains a lot a
lot
so it's just that economics doesn't care
about American Republicans no way it
never has I mean I've never cared avoid
saying the thing we're not supposed to
say but it also has to do with that so
um the fact that 2008 happened and
nothing ever came of it and they needed
something to blame it on and distract
for a while and also to control
populations
they had to do that and then do what
Tim's talking about see see what I did
there I didn't
so it's like figure it out folks maybe
you're talking about the global the I
guess call it the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland printing
selling the Federal Reserve money
talking about something else well I I I
think I know fever and and the bank of
international settlements is the old
system what they're proposing now with
bricks is going to be to get off of that
system
so when when Russia invades Ukraine they
threaten to rip them rip them from Swift
and so immediately they're like okay we
need something else because we cannot be
beholden to the U.S I'd be willing to
bet so they immediately started going
around and this this is years ago in
fact we know they were doing this and
pitching to these countries join us the
resistance and now with Ukraine and
everything that's going on and the US is
in total chaos I'd be willing to bet
and again this is very surface level
because I don't have access to class
that information I'd be willing to bet
that China's been subverting the us
through Tick Tock and through social
media our foreign adversaries have been
doing the same thing we have been
spinning around rope-a-dope while
they've been preparing all of this stuff
and there are Elites in the United
States who know what's happening and
said you know what if you can't beat
them join them no that's not only what's
happened but look at you can actually
look at this if you look at the bill
that just came out about unveiling who
runs the think tanks it's not just that
they've been rope-a-doping they have
been cashing out on this like they're
every single think tank in Washington DC
is owned by a different foreign country
and they're not like our friends they're
not like
England I mean even though England is
our actual biggest enemy people need to
start understanding
um it's like really really bad ones like
ones that are on like the state
department in one hand is creating lists
of bad countries that are sanctioned and
on the other hand sending their staff
over to work at think tanks that are
funded by those countries so like make
that make sense for me like that's
that's that it's not just it's not as
innocent even as rope-a-dope like I
think what Tim saying actually is
completely correct I just think it's a
gazillion times worse than that what do
we do just get some chickens get a gun
yeah you're on the right path watch
power watch the fall of the US Empire
well we're participating in it we also
forgot how they're shipping in all the
drugs to pacify the general the borders
the borders and destroying men and
testosterone so no one could Rebel and
fight listen when this is when all of
this is happening and then our border is
completely porous they don't care drugs
are pouring and they don't care our
economy is completely destroyed they
don't care
I'm just like okay they're participating
in it yeah yeah
I have to take some responsibility for
this yeah it's not it's not just bite
like in a trump Administration do you
know what happened to the immigration
bill it was shelved by the same people
that are running afpi right now which is
why I'm in a big old fight with them and
why like they're all can't understand
why I'm coming after them on Twitter but
like the same exact people that are
running afpi are the ones that decided
to shelve the immigration bill in favor
of having Kim Kardashian's uh uh more
more moments with celebrities like that
and release more criminals because all
that was at the top of the list of all
the Americans America First was
definitely about let's release more
criminals early not do immigration do
tax policy and plant a thousand trees I
don't remember that in any rally but
that's what we did and I hate I'm saying
we because I was in that office so it's
like I that wasn't what I was working on
like we were working on the immigration
bill and I can tell you it would have
solved all a lot of these issues do you
know that there's so much
um the the amount the number of
um uh what are they called those things
you put on trucks that come in through
ships like the shipping containers
they're that big right not just the
little FedEx package a package a giant
box that big the number of those that
are uninspected coming through our ports
is so low is so low that the number
itself is classified I'm not saying
anything classified by saying that if
the number is classified because if the
American people knew it would freak them
out that badly I don't think they care I
think we knew we found out that Joe
Biden was shipping children illegal
immigrant children across the country
and it was a story only for people who
read the news and half the country
despite the you know here's what I see
I see this story in front of us the
Petro dollar has been at risk for a long
time since the 70s since the 70s but
it's been getting progressively worse in
the past several years five six seven
years ago Russia starts dumping U.S
bonds China they've been preparing for
this the people running this country
they literally don't care Donald Trump
starts showing up our borders showing up
our defenses sealing our border bringing
jobs back getting factories from Mexico
back in boy did they lose their minds
and we've talked about this it may be
because of thucydides trap which is this
historical uh concept that whenever a a
large the dominant economic power is
about to be displaced by a rising
economic economic power War breaks out
at least 12 out of the 16 times in the
past 500 years so perhaps what's
happening is they're saying to avoid
world war three we will control
demolition the United States and then
rebuild up where it's growing rapidly
say China the brics countries and thus
we are watching the complete and total
collapse of of our country and what
happens is with expanded Universal
mail-in voting the American people who
are so blinded so stupid so ignorant and
so hate-filled are voting themselves
into Oblivion and you know what this is
what I was saying earlier I'm much I'm
very very much about individualism so my
my worst case scenario is it's not my
preferred ideal that this country goes
belly up but
you know I'm I'm fine with trying to
figure things out for myself and not
having to rely on other people and I and
I'm not saying I will be good at
surviving completely in the wilderness
no but you know I I we that this is one
of the reasons we get out to the middle
of nowhere we install solar panels with
massive batteries we get backup
generators we buy copper wires do that
though they if the country completely
falls apart there's not going to be a
they anymore it's going to be roving
bands of people desperate for food and
then what happens is communities isolate
each other call it a national divorce
whatever you want where we are right now
this is Maga country the the all the
neighbors out here they got big signs
flying the Trump Flags in in a second if
there was a major crisis there would be
a a a neighborhood watch meeting people
would know exactly what to do and how to
do it people would be fortified I'm not
saying I'm doing anything crazy prep or
like like Preppers do maybe we should
because because this is very alarming
the brics countries but I mean like 30
years worth of food and like you know
look it is enough I mean not if it's the
total I mean well yeah I mean but if
you're still if three years have gone by
you're still living on some bagged up
some badge you know fast food no no no
no listen listen here's what you do
when you store emergency food for the
apocalypse scenario yeah you never touch
it what you do is you always make sure
you're getting your food from natural
sources and only in extreme emergencies
do you do you tap into your your
reserves after three years ain't gonna
be no Chef Boyardee anymore no that's
going to be worth gold there's gonna be
some dude and he's going to be like
you're an unopened Chef Boyardee that's
right no no I want that case a nine
millimeter I'll give you anything for it
he opens it and there's mud in it
no no the cans just faded and filthy oh
I think would you get for a pack of
Hubba Bubba
you know he cracks it open takes his
finger and just puts in his mouth and
then instantly in his mind is
transported to being a little kid in a
beautiful suburb and his mom hands him
the bowl and he's like I love you mom
she's like I love you and then he
flashes back to reality his clothes are
ripped he's covered in dirt and he's
like
why that's funny look at this movie I
was talking to him I was talking to
Michael malice earlier he's got a book
coming out but he one thing he said one
of the things he said to me was people
in this country absolutely do not
realize what bad is that's what I'm
trying to say because he's the an expert
on North Korea what I'm trying to say is
like and and many other countries like
that what I'm trying to say is we don't
know we are so not prepared for what
it's like to not be a superpower I think
what what I'm saying is like getting to
the point where you're at where it's
like okay fine maybe there is an Ave
maybe it is roving gangs and maybe it
all that and everybody else everyone is
an influencer you know everyone in
Poland in my family jars their food has
a little plot of land where they grow
there yeah the Mormons will be we do
that because the Communists starved my
family
so people don't understand how bad it
could get it could get really bad really
quick and it's only about us I'm going
to become Amish well we're gonna go to
super chats okay what you want to say
yeah the last thing is
one thing that could happen because we
because we're not an Empire I mean it
might look kind of empirical you know
there's a bridge jumper we are an
American Republic and when the Roman
Republic fell it became an Empire so if
some strong man steps in and says run
turns this country into a junta and runs
it through the military goes around
kills whoever disagrees yeah if
something like a caesar were to appear
with a military force and people and
then we're like second fiddle to the
Chinese superstructure and we're just
kind of like a vassal State no first we
get to be the American Empire though
for 200 years no we need we need the
American Caesar and that's why when we
get the red Caesar we're gonna have a
handful of hundred years of good times
and that's going to be awesome and then
everything can fall apart but first I
insist on a red Caesar all right we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com and I just want to
give one last special thank you to
everybody who supported our song uh
genocide losing my mind the billboard
tracking period ended last night it
still keeps tracking for ever but that
was the big push we're starting to do
marketing and everything but seriously
thank you for checking out the song
listening to it streaming and edit your
playlists all that we still want to
promote it we still want you to listen
to the song and enjoy it but um we're
going to get the numbers on a billboard
on Tuesday and see how well we did so
thank you all so much we got pluriberry
who says a bunch of news outlets
reporting Russia is removing troops
sounds to me like he's getting ready to
Nuke also rolala land and Trinidad of
pressure
bidenisms the culture Warrior says I see
the step-on snack shirt got jacked by
some weird company on FB
yeah you know what are you gonna do
about it but I'll tell you what you can
do in the pinned in the chat right now
is our stand your ground rooster shirt
you can click that and uh buy it it is a
rooster and uh you know he's he's
raising his wings going man he's stand
your ground it says and it's because the
noble rooster he will rush to fight a
predator knowing he will die if it means
his hens will get but a few more seconds
to escape
be like the noble rooster stand your
ground stand up what you believe in yeah
can we get matching tattoos I'm not
gonna get that tattoo but you can get
the shirt dang it we gotta order
something you guys gotta hook me up with
some of these shirts so I got things to
wear on the plane oh yeah we got we can
have a step on step on snack and find
out yeah hook me up I'll mail you some
shirts yeah Luke's the shirt guy we just
we have like we have sillier shirts Luke
has the overt political funny ones yeah
I went over it weird stuff I got some
really crazy ones I can't even share
here all right yeah that's right that's
what I want Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Tim it's Veterans Day while many cozy at
home veterans were away from family some
worked the keyboard some replaced gear
some kicked down doors all signed that
blank check shout out to Veterans shout
out to Veterans absolutely and uh the
end of world war one I think you were
saying yeah today yeah Armistice Day is
that is is that the same day like always
Veterans Day and then of world war one
yeah they turned it into Veterans Day it
used to be called Armistice Day yes it
was celebrated globally and then uh
Americans when that was the biggest war
when they thought that was the war to
end all war right do you guys know about
the Christmas Armistice I think it was
called right yeah
it's when the French and the uh French
and the Germans came out of their
trenches Christmas Eve and they just
were like why are we even fighting they
started playing soccer they were like
hanging out smoking each other
nicotine nationalism smoking cigarettes
together and the next morning the French
commanders were like all right it's time
for you to go kill them and they're like
we're not and they're like they know I'm
gonna shoot you in the back you better
in this French like all right this is
how War works yeah this is early 1914
the beginning of the war as well to
point that out before all four years of
everyone killing each other so it's the
worst possible ways you still didn't
know why they were fighting that's the
weirdest thing though yeah do they ever
do we ever I'm sorry why were we in
African man hey hey someone killed
Prince Ferdinand man you gotta go to war
over that right there's a lot of heroin
in Afghanistan
all right Tara few says corn loved you
in Stargate it is hands down my favorite
TV show thank you for all you do sweet
well thank you there you go and then I
mean here it comes Alex Ritter says
Jonas Quinn in the house now get
Christopher Judge
he is an entertaining fellow I will say
David says Jonas Quinn was a Mary Sue
but coronemic nailed it do you think he
was a Mary Sue I I'm not sure exactly
what a Mary Sue is it's like a innocent
no okay it's a character who's uh uh
powerful through deus ex machina like
you introduce a character and they're
just powerful like they don't go through
the development and earning of oh like
in Star Wars when the girls always are
better like we watch you know I mean I
was no Jar Jar Binks but I I did you
know I did my part so Rey is a Mary Sue
exactly she like she uses the force and
she lifts like 50 times she's better
than all the guys that we spent three
movies watching train just to have one
shot at the train she didn't have to
train at all it's just because she's a
chick she picks up the thing and she's
better than everybody Did your guy just
appear and he was super strong well you
know it's just it's my mental capacity
that you know sir served my character so
well I was yes I was I was able to
absorb huge amounts of data and and and
and regurgitated belt buckle are you
guys seeing this oh no that was my my
great uncle's belt buckle can I get a
face thing on camera
thank you
all right keto Master says Tim
Republicans at large may have won but I
feel like I've lost I'm in Oregon and an
evil Harpy will now be the governor and
measure 114 past yeah that's insane you
see that the gun control thing move it's
like you need lessons you need permits
you can't buy you can't buy guns anymore
where is that what's that Morgan
[Music]
um
they think that they're gonna be able to
vote those Easter and be able to vote
themselves exactly they need to secede
so it's going to be instead of Oregon
it's gonna be Oregon no no
here's it doesn't make sense let me let
me let me let me let me give you some
logic I used to give my friends when I
was a little kid because I was a I Was A
Gifted bad influence that influence so
I'm talking to a friend of mine and I'm
like hey you want to go skate and he
goes I can't I'm grounded and I was like
what does that mean he's like I'm not
allowed to go outside and I was like
dude what do you mean you're not allowed
to go outside my parents told me I can't
leave the house and I was like so what
happens if you leave the house and he
goes I'll get grounded more and then I'm
like okay so if you're grounded and you
leave the house they'll ground you more
right and then what happens if you leave
the house after that and he goes they'll
ground me more and I'm like are you
following the logic here right and
they're like oh and I'm like dude if all
they're going to do is ground you and
you leave and they ground you more
grounding isn't doing anything to you so
my attitude with the secession from
Morgan is like
these these counties voted to do it or
they voted to put it on a bill or I
can't remember exactly what it was and
then everyone's like yeah well Congress
will never let it happen and the states
won't let it happen and I'm like let
what does that mean yeah you as the
people voted to do it so what happens
next like my my thought is if the people
in this County are like okay we've
seceded what is anyone gonna do is
Oregon going to send State Police to
your county and then remove all of the
government perhaps I guess but if the
people who live there are like we
seceded what are they going to do lfg
start arresting every single person if
they don't pay their state taxes sure
and then I guess the issue is if people
who live in these areas agree to abide
by the rules and laws of of Portland of
the of the West Coast then they did not
secede they just said they wanted to
right right my point is if you've got
all these counties all over the country
that are saying we hereby vote to secede
and I'm like so then
then you did right you stopped paying
taxes you stopped abiding you started
like if if there's a Northern District
in Colorado it's like okay you vote if
you voted for this does that mean you've
called up the the governor of you know
Idaho or what's what's north of Colorado
it's not Idaho is it no it's not it's
okay Wyoming yeah yeah so yeah yeah not
getting the visual um did you call them
up and say hey we're you now and and
what did they say has any of that
occurred right now in in Western
Maryland they wrote letters saying they
wanted to secede these Three Counties
and join West Virginia and it's like
Maryland in their secessionist uh
Tendencies actually actually no Maryland
did not want us a seat in the Civil War
yeah they were way up I know Maryland
was a slave state uh south of
Mason-Dixon but uh but they they but
they I mean they they were uh Southern
slaves they did not secede but they
didn't but I thought I thought that they
were they that they were they did
succeed but they got taken over
immediately backwards nope and they did
not secede uh in the initial secession I
believe I could be wrong guys I know
many of you know more about the Civil
War than me but uh seven states seceded
and there were four slave states that
didn't no I'm sorry there was more than
four slave face that there was uh
probably seven I think others but only
four others joined in the South several
months later because of Abraham
Lincoln's call for volunteers right so
uh Maryland was a slave state so it was
Delaware
they remained in the union and then uh
the federal government arrested 30 some
odd assembly members from Maryland
because they're in favor of it but the
overall majority were not in favor of
secession okay so did the federal
government just set it set up like
military all over Maryland oh totally
Abraham Lincoln was like ah declare from
DC to Pennsylvania anyone will be
arrested for any reason without charge
or trial and then everyone's like sounds
good to me and then he went around
arresting people and there was like a
famous case of some guy who was just
flipping them off and saying screw you
guys so they arrested him for no reason
and held him until after the war and
peoples
and they wrote that 11 states seceded
from the Union out of fear that slavery
would be ended and it's like man I've
like read a few academic papers in the
Civil War went on a few tours and I
already know that's not true it was
seven and then Sumter happened and a
bunch of other stuff happened in fact
the crazy thing is I was reading about
I think it was the first battle of Bull
Run the South could have invaded DC and
won instantly but they did not want to
start a war with the north they were
trying just to stop the north from
coming into the South and so like after
the first battle everyone's in panic
they're running and screaming because
Virginia is right there on DC yeah and
so they did that part of it I mean
that's the thing if you want to talk
about your Masonic thing I mean the
original line of the capital was meant
to be lined up with the with the with
the temple right the original Stone I
know only know because I jog by it
almost yeah it was where they it was
where they they lined up the whole city
outwards from there it was meant to
include the center of the city it was
meant to include Virginia and it they
just cut it off at the river mind Fury
says I knew that voice sounded familiar
Captain Alvarez from Star Trek Renegades
short-lived web series version of Star
Trek cool uh yeah it was fun it was
great I mean which era was it in when
was it was it the 90s era uh no no no no
we shot that we we shot it maybe 12
years ago or something like that it
wasn't that long ago but it was uh you
know maybe in 2013 or 14 but it was it
was an attempt to do a new series for uh
for Star Trek but an independent kind of
uh take on it and they just couldn't get
the uh you know the the rights and and
everybody to get on board they ended up
having to do the set the second season
they did uh they ended up having to drop
the Star Trek from the name and just
call it Renegades yeah they called a fan
film now oh yeah when I searched them
yeah exactly legomoth again says Jaffa
Cree but in all seriousness you were
awesome in that show and it's great to
see your face again for so many years
thank you right on great username yeah I
used to I just thought that movie a
great new user named Jaffa Cree
I used to uh uh like reference Star Trek
a whole lot and then a bunch of people
started saying if you like Star Trek you
gotta watch sg1 yeah and then I was like
yeah yeah I'll get to it I'll get to it
you know I'll watch at some point and
then sci-fi started showing sg1 I don't
know his Comet I think
and then uh it was like 4 P.M yeah four
five and six I think they would have
three episodes back to back just
straight through and I'd just be sitting
there just watching for three hours
every day and I was like this Show's
awesome yeah it is what I liked most
about it was the fact that it took place
in present time but was a Sci-Fi you
know most sci-fi's are you know some
place in the far away future or whatever
and you can't really but this is like
something you could really hang on to
and go wow I I feel like I could be a
part of this like I feel like the
Stargate is real I mean I've had at
conventions I've done I've had people
convinced to a t that it's real and they
created the series to hide the real star
game we know we know it's real dude we
we've all seen the episode Wormhole
extreme we know that was a signal to all
the fans that it was real the whole time
yeah but we know it's not real real
end of story guys let's move on well
it's funny because the Stargate project
actually had nothing to do with portals
was it like psychic powers yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah and that was real
Stargates Native Americans would go
inside of a circle that they would like
draw out and actually project into the
special projection but that's what
that's what the the the the pyramids
were become well some say were
originally used for as astral projection
Chambers because they're on those
the pyramid itself is built but that's a
whole nother yeah
I'll talk about that after the show you
mean those pyramids those those uh uh
slave bills
when are we gonna when are we gonna um
tear down those monuments to slavery
that's what I want to know yeah when
they can prove the slaves built them all
right Jay Williams sees us this message
is for Ian please sir could you check
your Instagram DMS to see the idea have
and details it's a platform based on
incentivizing Innovation and connecting
individuals for the correct reasons I'll
send you more details if you have any
questions thank you yes I will all right
well it sounds like my DMs that sucks
yeah I'm not saying I'm gonna respond
but I'll definitely check it out I get a
lot of messages
like scripts I got that are like like
the founding fathers the musical and
they're like I had this idea I've
polished it off just for you and I'm
like please don't but I will encourage
you build the thing and then get to me
with the finished product and I can help
you Market it it's a lot better than
asking me to start a new project right
now all right James hates everything
says Corin please reboot Parker Lewis oh
I've I've had some conversations about
that really like the official Studio
stuff we can uh well there was there was
an attempt by uh by by the creators to
to pitch a version of it uh that that
was turned down but I have my own
version that I'm dying to pitch uh
Parker Lewis Can't Win and it's the
reverse it's him now he's old he's lost
everything Miss Musso is the mayor of
the town lemmer is the local sheriff
Kubiak is now a famous wrestler Mikey's
a famous musician Jerry's a district
court judge which is actually true Troy
Slayton is a judge out in in California
now but uh and that you know everything
that he does just turns to crap
yeah yeah yeah so it's like him trying
to you know relive the old get everybody
shucking and driving trying to get some
new thing off of it everything is
thwarted by Miss Musso and this and he's
living on people's couches and it's the
exact opposite it's so sad though I
think it would be hilarious dark comedy
in the end he wins in the end he wins
yeah Parker always wins yeah so as
Parker Lewis Can't Win for the first
four seasons then season five is back to
Parker Lewis who owns the rights is the
the network uh Sony TV okay yeah make it
happen man I know it would be hilarious
yeah doesn't that suck though that's
where all my dad's stuff is that people
ask me all the time they're like doesn't
your dad have like 30 unmade scripts and
I'm like yeah and they're all owned by
the movie studios that were paying him
to write them while he smoked cigars and
hung out with the Hell's Angels like I
can't not a bad not a bad life though
that's what I'm saying and he wonders
what he's like can't you go like he like
conveniently forgets is he a stroke like
15 years ago I mean sorry but you did
and he'll he'll like he'll be like hey
can you why don't you because he knows I
make movies now he's like you you
daughter you make my Curtis LeMay movie
now and I'm like Dad I can't you wrote
it when you were getting paid all that
money by Warner Brothers remember when
you were just hanging out that's why
yeah you might I mean if you could find
his old contracts you could see if it's
owner perpetuity or not but all right
Josh Coppock says give me Ryan's Pagan
rocks so I can grind them into holy
rosaries God Wilson I might have a good
one for you well so the the idea is just
for those because I see some people
commenting about it is if you become a
member at timcast.com and watch our
members only shows any one of them Tales
from the inverted world uh uh Cass
castle and the Tim guest uncensored show
we are going to just scroll in grab a
random comment send you an email and be
like hey we just it's just random we saw
your name we picked it and we're going
to send you something from the show uh
the way I see it is we got a table full
of garbage here Ian give me that bag
behind your laptop
yeah dude see that's so much a bunch of
balloons here's a good example this is a
bag of balloons
it's just sitting on the table for no
reason and it's because no there's a
reason it's because of Luke inflated
these to put
I needed to compete with Libby Evans he
put them in his shirt and now this
garbage is just sitting here so I'm like
we need to get rid of all this garbage
what do we do with it we give it away
yeah we make you responsible for the
garbage so we'll uh we'll we're like
once a week we'll have someone hit up
the people in the comments just be like
hey we've got uh it'll always be
something relevant like we're not going
to send you a can you know like or a
bottle of water this is kind of cool
yeah that's not good that's not garbage
that's before the Federal Reserve I like
it yes what money used to be yeah and
States would issue their own currency
but uh an example do you think this has
sir
a lot of sides though I don't know but
we'll send you stuff like that we'll
send you uh uh like Tim's old lint Roll
paper where he's no we're not gonna your
lit would sell it
we do have the auction thing we can
auction off the weirdest stuff splurges
boogers on the tissue yeah please the
contents of the studio garbage
we found a way to get rid of it it's
better than recycling is it ends up you
know just being dumped off the coast
there's a company that would send
garbage to politicians yes all right
here's a good one Steve Smith he says
this will be the last episode of timcast
IRL I watch I can no longer support a
show that picks DeSantis over Trump and
calls for Banning Tick Tock thank you
Tim and Ian for putting on so many great
shows seven years
Manny Tick Tock is a great idea
Tick Tock is the worst thing that that's
almost as bad as the fentanyl that they
sent us it's digital fentanyl that's
right it's digital fentanyl Tick Tock is
just it's 100 digital phone and the
biggest issue is that yeah like goodbye
and we'll clarify too I've not
definitively said DeSantis should be the
person I've said there should be an Open
Primary to figure out who has the the
ability the Republicans problem right
now is they have too many Star players
and the Democrats problem is they don't
even have one they literally have no one
that can even speak English seriously I
just want to finish 22. that's all I'm
saying is I'm just like I refuse to get
involved in the 24 conversation until
we've at least got an answer on 22. like
I'm so excited like it's gonna be great
we got big New Year's plans all right
what do we got here we've got Noah POA
says actually the ISU in Assassin's
Creed we're from a prehistoric
civilization unimportant but I couldn't
resist the fact check okay well there
you go and played that game in a decade
or whatever so
Chris Moncton says had to search for
timcast tonight normally near the top of
my feed must be doing something right
yeah they're they're they're they're
rather unhappy with us probably over
hosting Milo I can only I can only show
that would do it that will do it they're
like Milo loves LSD by the way he was
saying like Trump has got to do it Trump
has got to win Trump's and then YouTube
is probably like oh geez oh no he's
promoting Trump what do we do they love
it when we're like DeSantis yeah I
didn't get a notification that's weird
yeah they made a fictional depiction of
Milo and DeSantis doing awful things
that we described in an after show I
watched that full episode oh it's
horrible it was disgusting and that
wasn't the craziest part of the whole
series
uh no no no no no but clearly it's Milo
and then the whole thing they said it
was staged with 20 000 white
supremacists and Patriot front groups
protesting in Chicago and then setting
up a terrorist attack to kill all black
lawyers all right yes that's the premise
of the the episode these people live in
a weird way I need to see that yes
that's the premise of the entire episode
sorry if I ruined it for you but it's
absolutely deranged and they keep making
these like slides crazy racist Jabs that
are just like mind-boggling and just
like so very low effort and not
intelligent at all I'm man yeah
places that cannot be on
how both Hobbes and Lake are addressing
the Maricopa County vote count is a huge
indicator on how they would handle other
issues plaguing their constituents
Kerry uh carizona for governor
absolutely Carrie likes fantastic she
better win the way she is she's the vibe
what do we got
Pauline says Jonas Quinn was such a
great character I love that he wasn't
just a written character he was clearly
based on Corin and the fascinating
person that he is very cool oh thanks
how much do I owe you did they give you
leeway when you're building the
character at first and then I was banned
from using props after a scene when I
when I was uh uh I I was we were doing a
scene in in the main room where you talk
about uh all the next mission and all
that you know the Big Board Room and I
had one line in the whole entire scene
and they had me standing by a whole big
fruit pile you know on a table so I
started peeling this bright orange
orange the whole time until I get to my
one line of dialogue so I can like eat
the orange while I'm saying it you know
but what they and they were fine with it
but then when they got in the editing
room they realized every time they cut
to the wide shot I'm over there just
like every healing this one everybody's
like what is he doing and they're not
listening to anything else that's going
on and after that they were like yeah
okay unless it's scripted you can't use
it because I was I had a banana in outer
space scene that was iconic
it wasn't scripted here we go was it was
it scary actually going through the
Stargate on the show to transport to
other worlds yeah yeah that's what
people have asked me it's surreal so no
seriously they really have they're like
what's it like going through the
Stargate and I'm like well you know
there's this big thing called a green
screen that's right there you know and
then there's this this line that you
cross between where the the gate is and
then where the green screen is and you
you step across that so you're saying
there is a start that's it I'm just
getting that clearer yeah
it'll only transport you uh an inch and
a half through present time and through
the air were you ever worried the iris
would come down on you as you were
passing through the Stargate okay now
I'm just done I'm done well it was
called the the giant toilet bowl is what
kind of was everybody you know somebody
and wasn't it like they had they only
they had one static prop and then one
mobile prop and so they had to keep
using the mobile one for all the
different scenes on every different
planet I think there were yeah there was
there was a number of Stargates they had
and they had some that didn't work and
some that did so I mean the one that was
the the primary one in in the SGC I mean
that thing could work all the Chevrons
opened and closed it spun around it lit
up I mean I was like the same one from
the movie like did they just no no it
wasn't it wasn't the exact same what was
a new one yeah because I remember
reading about how fans would be like how
come this one will rotate and lock in
the things but then outside on other
planets it just lights up yeah because
it's way too expensive to be bringing
that that thing all around all the plug
that's a good show man if you guys
haven't watched it it's it's an
addictive show it's super good I love
how they use like ancient god mythology
into this that's why I'm sorry to it
yeah yes I love that
all right Druid Arrow says
constitutional Anarchist party
Libertarians constitutionalists and
anarchists form a party three branches
of government government why not full
three parties since half population
doesn't vote maybe they will fall in
these views okay I like it
we cast our votes by not voting
Anarchy just means no government not no
law correct I think we're at the point
no rulers yeah and uh with no no
Authority and our key yeah you could
have law though no no like no there's no
Authority so so you as an individual
could and then who's going to listen to
you he's going to hold the weapons yes
well not weapons but like who would
punish you right we will enforce though
this is why this is why I say that uh
antifa is not Anarchist they try to
claim they are but they're not they're
the opposite they're like status but but
it's not even that it's right if you're
a group that has a name and a brand and
flies a flag with quartets and you beat
people until they do what you want you
are not an anarchist sounds kind of
fascist yeah
Anarchy is more like trying to convince
someone
so you go to someone and say I'm going
to try and convince you to do something
non-aggression principle damn right I'd
be thrown out of that Society in five
seconds
Stephen C says Tick-Tock is nothing but
an online insane asylum not in China and
China it's very wholesome
yeah it's true yeah it's all education
me and our people too you can't even be
on after 10 pm what yeah you're only
allowed a certain amount of time on that
platform seriously
Jeremy abrahamson abrahamson says
another thing of this on the Civil War
to bear in mind is that the popular
opinion of the north was that the slave
states had an unfair influence over the
federal government such as with the
Fugitive Slave Act but they weren't
actually uh adhering to that so well the
future
I did make it more complicated because
it messed with all the just push push at
the right side where's the right side
yeah there you go what were you saying
about the Slave Act Amanda
um because it took the law on the road
so it was very I think it it it it it it
made it more complex because like
that meant that in a free state a slave
would be under the law of the state that
he came from versus the state he was in
which makes things much more complex and
not
functional than but like just having a
line and being like under here is the
agriculture world where we require
slavery and over here is the the north
where we don't
uh the future who passed the Fugitive
Slave Act it was it was actually
relatively old compared to when the
Civil War happened it had been around
for a while and it wasn't being enforced
so uh slaves it's kind of a non-issue
yeah and then the north would be like we
don't care well it was a serious issue
The South was like the federal
government won't actually enforce the
law to protect uh what they viewed as
their rights and so this that became
reading distrust part of the issue yeah
so taking an old law and demanding the
federal government use the old laws led
to a civil war we've got to keep that no
no no no no no no no no no that's not
why I'm not saying that's what happened
that's a contributing like amongst many
other issues like that's a contributing
issue amongst others but like that
that's something that makes it more
complex you're taking your law on the
road if they're if they're if there was
no slavery there would not have been a
civil war but the fighting and the cause
of it was extremely eventually there was
going to be a civil war there's a law
now what they used to prosecute
journalists it's a trash in the joints
there's like a what is that called
so if people are starting to to appeal
to federal government to hey use the
Espionage Act on this person Obama
yes yes like Obama all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com as I mentioned comment on a
Members Only video and then we might
pick like five people once per week like
maybe on a Friday we're gonna get
started probably next week and then we
will act we'll hit you up and be like
hey where can we send you something cool
and uh we've got Post-its as I mentioned
that Milo filled out basically
explaining the censorship of YouTube
they're hilarious they're really cool
and we'll send those out there might be
like eight of them then we've got you
know Luke's bazunga balloons it's just
knickknacks
we'll send them out
Ian's got rocks we'll see we'll see what
you get like this one so uh again smash
that like button you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast Amanda do you want to shout
anything out
uh plot against the president on DVD
makes a really good gift for your Boomer
parents or grandparents and it's
available on target Amazon Walmart and
uh you should watch it anyway if you
want to know what's happening right on
corn you got anything to shout out uh
first I gotta shout you out thanks so
much for her yeah thank you for having
me here and I really appreciate that
it's been for sure man uh as far as that
goes you can just you can follow me on
uh on Twitter or Instagram those are
about the only two I do uh I do have a
fan site on on Facebook but it's I am
coronemic the letter I the letter M and
my name core name expelled like it is uh
and uh and there you can get updates
because I got too much going on to
explain in such a short amount of time
so follow me there and I'll fill you in
that was that was great and extremely
entertaining thank you for both of you
guys for coming uh my website is Luke
uncensored.com I did a very interesting
video about uh Dave Chappelle's
interview with Oprah which I think
relates to what's happening to Kanye
West and Kyrie Irving lots of different
things that I think are worth talking
about deep down the rabbit hole I
discussed them specifically on Luke
uncensor.com see you there for the
conversation and I think after this show
it's official we gotta have my and
Amanda on at the same time I would love
with them together I don't drink with
booze all together in one show do not
drink so it's not good Milo I love Milo
and he's always been very nice to me and
I can't wait to hang out with them
tonight you're both around Sunday
probably yeah sure fine we can do Sunday
like I'll do it yeah yeah that'd be cool
I also love a good Friday night Rodeo
where Tim is the bull thank you for
hosting and letting us ride you all
night Kim how wonderful what you do man
that's right love you and uh great to
see you guys Serge you're the best hey
love you man show it was a good time
thanks guys for tuning in I'm glad I
remember the end of it this time it's
nice we're gonna have Clips up all
weekend as we normally do become a
member at timcast.com and we'll see you
all next week cheers